florida republican congressman matt  gates reportedly is being investigated  by the justice department for  allegedly having a sexual relationship  with a 17-year-old girl  now that was first reported by the new  york times gates has seen  since confirmed the federal  investigation to axios saying quote  the allegations against me are as  searing as they are false he goes on to  say  the allegations are rooted in an  extortion effort against his family for  25 million dollars  new york's new york times reported the  allegations include that gates  paid for this girl to travel with him  gates says the justice department is  trying to criminalize his sexual conduct  when he was quote a single guy and that  no one was  underage we'll continue to follow this  developing story